Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Gesichtsbuch Netzpolitik.
Facebook Like Strike, werdet Fan der Seite und die kriegt immer neu.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, es nimmt kein Ende. Äh
Heute haben wir was, hundertvier, hundert äh vierte Ausgabe von äh diesem außergewöhnlichen Format, was äh mal der Anspruch hatte wöchentlich zu erscheinen. Wir sind äh.
Diesen Anspruch versucht zu erfüllen,
Da du hast ja gesagt, wir sollen nicht über Facebook reden, aber ich will ganz kurz noch was sagen. Ähm es wurde ja in der letzten Folge dann kommentiert, dass ähm meine Äußerungen zu Facebook von einer gewissen äh Überheblichkeit gekennzeichnet wären.
Womit? Mit Recht.
Nein, diesem äh dieser dem möchte ich entschieden widersprechen, denn,
Wenn jemand mit so viel äh Computerhype wissen wie ich an einem Ding scheitert, dann äh,
dann äh denke ich, ist das äh ist das erwähnenswert. Und ich habe mir, ich habe da heute nochmal drüber nachgedacht und mir ist völlig unklar, weil ich heute auch nochmal versucht habe, da was zu Facebooken. Ähm wie Menschen dieses Ding bedienen können,
Und damit ist mir klar geworden, warum die Digitalisierung unserer Gesellschaft so schleppend vorangeht, warum die Menschen irgendwie die ganze Zeit mit Computer und Internet und so, alles diese verstehe ich nicht, verstehe ich nicht, verstehe ich nicht. Die benutzen Windows und Facebook.
Und,
und dann und wenn sie dann mich fragen so ja ähm also das sehe ich natürlich ganz andere Dinge mit Computern realisieren kann,
wenn man sich, sage ich mal, schon einfache Dinge so kompliziert macht, dann verstehe ich auch so diesen gesamten Nimbus, der dann so diesen Hacker, die Sage umwogene Hacker, der macht mit einem Computer etwas
oder vielleicht sogar mit einem Computer nicht ihm selber gehört oder passiert was unter und zwar etwas, was er
beabsichtigt hat, ja? Und nicht irgendwie so ein random äh Ding, also mir ist völlig unklar. Aber das ein das ein äh ein ein Verständnisdefizit auf meiner Seite, denn Windows hat sich durchgesetzt, Facebook hat sich durchgesetzt,
Und ich bisher nur teilweise.
Den würde ich auch widersprechen wollen.
Und der aber das das Ding.
Linus, du bist auch schon längst.
Ja
Bei bei ADN oder was?
Ähm na sonst halt so in der anderen Welt eben. Also äh.
Ja. Bei, bei, bei, bei, bei, ähm, beim Deutschland Radio war ich letztens. Anlässlich anlässlich, äh, ein Jahr, äh, snowen,
habe ich äh habe ich äh wurde mir äh angeboten, doch den zur Prime Time, ja? Sagen sie, das ist unsere beste Sendezeit. Oh, super, beste Sendezeit, wann ist das denn? Ja, um zehn vor sieben. Darf's dann erstmal Wecker stellen?
Ein Grund warum Hacker so wenig Präsenz in bestimmten Medien.
Aber ist übrigens ein ein Geheimnis, warum der, warum der Wolfgang Bosbach immer seinen Scheiß im Deutschlandradio zählen darf? Der steht früh auf.
Steht früh auf. Na ja. Ne, ist auch generell, wenn man so äh Aktionismus äh machen will so und da muss man halt auch mal so ein Morgenmagazin irgendwie durch äh ziehen und das heißt halt früh aufstehen.
Habe ich gemacht. Die haben ja aber trotzdem nur acht Minuten gegeben und ich war dann grade mal so irgendwie wach und warmted. Äh und dann meinten sie jetzt zu Nachrichten oder so. Na ja, da.
Minuten. Das ist viel. Na ja.
Acht Minuten. Das ist viel, ne? Zur zur besten Sendezeit, keine Sau, daher sieben Uhr. Ich bitte dich.
Na gut, aber ist so acht Prozent einer Stunde, das ist schon da äh relativ.
Acht Prozent, acht Minuten sind nicht acht Prozent einer Stunde. Stunde hat sechzig Minuten. Oh, das sind aber jetzt ganz, ganz großes Roll-Eis. Gibt's das bei Facebook so ein Roll-Eyes.
Gibt's bestimmt ein Emoji dazu. Mit Emoji-Tastatur.
Acht durch sechzig. Das waren.
Ja. Sollte jetzt jemand den Eindruck haben, dass wir uns auf Erde überhebliche Art und Weise über Facebook irgendwie erheben und lächerlich machen, ja? Und das Ganze einfach abgehoben und äh eingebildet, kommentieren.
Ja. Okay. Bevor wir anfangen hier mit äh ernsthaft? Team, meinst du? Themen.
Meinst du? Tolle äh äh tolle Idee? Ja, lass mal anfangen mit äh Themen.
Wir haben drei drei Gerichts äh Urteile aus dem Bereich des Urheberrechts, die äh irgendwie so ihren Weg durch das Internet an Facebook vorbei zu uns gefunden haben,
Das Erste ist ein, ich kann jeweils zu den Urteilen gar nicht so viel sagen, weil
Allein schon das erste, äh der Rechtsstreit bei diesem EuGH, dass also das erste Urteil, das wir besprechen, ist ein Urteil des äh EuGH, der äh eine quasi eine Urheberrechtsausnahme postuliert für Webserver,
Websurfer. Tschuldigung. Das wäre schön.
Sie sagen, wer geschützte Werke im Web nur betrachtet, also nicht ausdruckt oder herunterlädt, verstößt dadurch nicht gegen das Urheberrecht
Daher war irgendwie eine sehr skurrile ähm ein sehr skurriler Rechtsstreit äh der Hintergrund zwischen der Public Relations Consultants Association und der News Paper Lifestyle Agency
den ich nicht verstanden habe. Aber der entscheidende Punkt ist natürlich hier,
Dieses Übliche und das äh das ist der der, der entscheidende Streithund, der da berührt wird, wenn also eine,
Webseite, sagen wir, in dem Fall ging es auch tatsächlich um Webseiten, den Weg auf unseren Bildschirm findet, dann
ist sie natürlich auch im Rahmen unseres Computers vertreten und das kann man technisch als eine.
Kopie bezeichnen. Ähm aber.
Diese Kopie zum Cashing, ja oder das gibt's ja dann auch nochmal, wird wahrscheinlich auch nochmal als Cashdatei offen auf der Festplatte abgelegt. Man weiß es nicht, das ist ja alles sowieso Magie. Ähm und aber sie sagen, diese Kopie,
technisch tatsächlich stattgefunden habende Kopie. Ähm ist vorübergehend flüchtig,
oder begleitend und ein integraler und wesentlicher Teil eines technischen Verfahrens.
Ja? Denn du kannst nicht eine Webseite anschauen ohne das streng genommen eine Kopie stattfindet. Nämlich die Kopie von dem Webserver, wo sie ist, zu deinem Computer und dort ist sie dann im Rahmen oder im Cash auf der Festplatte auf jeden Fall Zeit
für eine kurze Zeit vertreten. Aber diese Kopie ist eben Teil eines technischen Verfahrens und deswegen nicht eine Kopie,
Und deswegen, das war auch lange Zeit der Streit. Wir erinnern uns da an andere Verfahren äh und äh Rechtsstreitereien, auf die ich dann gleich auch nochmal zu sprechen komme. Das hat also der EUGH,
Das ist schon mal ganz schön, wenn der EuGH das sagt, weil das ja dann auch ähm für ganz eu geht, ne, für für ganz Europa oder was oder für alle, die sich an diesen EuGH berufen wollen würden.
Im Prinzip das gleiche Urteil bekommt zum zweiten, hat gefällt, das Amtsgericht Hannover,
Ähm und die haben gesagt, das Anschauen eines Streams ist nur bei offensichtlich rechtswidriger Vorlage,
als als strafbar zu beanstanden,
oder als illegal zu veranstalten. Und da geht es nämlich um diese Red Tube Abmahnungen. Wir erinnern uns, das war ein Thema, was wir relativ lange hier auch äh oder relativ häufig hier behandelt haben, wo es um die Abmahnungen ging,
von Menschen, die Streams angeschaut haben. Das war sehr äh und bis heute bleibt es nebulös, wie der äh die abmahnende Firma, wie hieß sie noch gleich,
irgendwie diese abmahnende Firma ist überhaupt herausgefunden hat, dass die Leute die Streams angeschaut haben mit den Schaukelvideos,
aber.
Auch nicht so richtig, wo es auch nicht so richtig eine Aufklärungsbereitschaft gab, hatte ich so.
Genau das haben sie auch vermieden. Ähm aber sie haben sich genau auf das Gleiche berufen, nämlich darauf, dass eine Kopie stattgefunden hätte.
Ja? Und ähm,
ähm dass äh Amtsgericht Hannover war's glaube ich, ja, das Amtsgericht Hannover hat gesagt,
Streaming ist nach Ansicht des Amtsgerichtes jedenfalls dann nach Paragraph vierundvierzig A Nummer Absatz zwei äh Urheberrecht zulässig,
Wenn kurzfristig eine nicht offensichtliche, eine nicht offensichtlich rechtswidrige Vorlage gestreamt wird.
Und das Gericht sagt, offensichtlich rechtswidrig ist eine Vorlage dann oder ein Video dann, wenn es ein
aktueller Kinofilm ist oder ein äh oder eine Fernsehserie, die noch vor ihrem offiziellen äh Start steht, ja, also man sagt, okay ähm,
Quasi das Streaming von Breaking Bad äh würde darunter fallen, weil es offensichtlich noch nicht für Deutschland ähm äh erhältlich ist. Ein Kinofilm, der der sich aktuell im Kino befindet,
würde darunter fallen, aber äh sowas wie ein ein drei Jahre altes äh Schaukelvideo eben nicht. Ja, weil da kann ja keiner wissen, ob das jetzt gerade ähm.
Ob das nicht vielleicht einfach schon äh so alt ist, dass man's frei zugänglich macht oder ob sich vielleicht von vorneherein einen Creative Communes Schaukelvideo war. Und äh.
Und gibt's die denn auch schon?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich äh es gab mal irgendwie so eine es gab mal irgendwie so ein drei D Ding da, müssen wir beim Netz für Tik Or gucken, ist schon ein paar Jahre her.
Drei D gleich.
Ja, ja, ich glaube, die haben das aber irgendwie auf Creative, müsste man nochmal schauen. Müssen wir nochmal schauen.
3D, CC Jokelvideos.
Ja. Das ist die Zukunft.
Auf jeden Fall.
So und dann äh das war so das Urteil ist aber äh des Amtsgerichts Hannover äh zu den Abmahnungen. Auch hier natürlich zu begrüßen äh grundsätzlich. Und,
Dann gab es noch ein Urteil und jetzt muss ich kurz schauen ähm.
Welches äh welches Gericht das war. Äh da genau, das war ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Gericht, nämlich der Bundesgerichtshof,
Über dieses Urteil hatten wir auch schon besprochen äh gesprochen. Das war das Urteil, welches sie am achten Januar gefällt haben. Da ging es um ein Familienvater, der nicht für die Rechtsverletzung seines,
Stiefsohns haften wollte. Ja, da ging's also um die Frage der Störerhaftung, Lokbuchnetzpolitik berichtete.
Ähm und da geht also jetzt diese Urteilsbegründung,
noch über dieses Familienverhältnis hinaus und der Rechtsanwalt also da wird also gesagt wird über ein so der Bundesgerichtshof wird über einen Internetanschluss eine Rechtsverletzung begangen,
Ist eine tatsächliche Vermutung für die Täterschaft des Anschlussanhabers nicht begründet,
Wenn zum Zeitpunkt der Rechtsverletzung auch andere Personen diesen Anschluss benutzen konnten,
Dies ist insbesondere dann der Fall, wenn der Internetanschluss zum Zeitpunkt der Rechtsverletzung nicht hinreichend gesichert war oder bewusst anderen Personen zur Nutzung überlassen wurde. Das heißt, hier gehen wir sehr konkret,
auf die Störerhaftung ein, Störerhaftung
der Grund, warum wir verhindern wollen, dass unsere Nachbarn, unser unser WLAN mitbenutzen, nämlich weil sie dann äh Urheberrechts äh Verletzungen oder andere äh Probleme
damit in die Welt setzen könnten, für die wir dann haftbar gemacht werden. Stich äh Stichwort an dieser Stelle, wie gesagt, die sogenannte Störerhaftung, die,
Wir erinnern uns auch vor einigen Jahr, vor etwas über einem Jahr, hier in Berlin auch zu so einer Welle der äh WLAN-Schließungen in den Cafes geführt hatte.
Ähm.
Und die also eine große äh Rechtsunsicherheit für alle war, wenn man sagte, okay, wenn du ein oder die Urteile bis dahin in die Richtung ging, wenn du irgendwie ein WLAN, anderen Leuten frei zugänglich machst und die damit Mist bauen, dann bist du daran schuld.
Beziehungsweise zumindest für den Mist, den sie bauen, haftbar. Und dem widerspricht an dieser Stelle äh,
wiederholt und äh ausdrücklich der Bundesgerichtshof und auch das ist natürlich eine sehr schöne Sache, weil das äh in konsequent ausgelegt dieses Urteil ähm es uns vielleicht auch wieder mehr ermöglichen wird,
ähm anderen Menschen Internetzugang zu geben ohne äh eine ein besonders ausführliches Vertrauensverhältnis äh zu ihnen äh haben zu müssen.
Also, ich meine, ist das nicht im Prinzip vielleicht deute ich das jetzt äh falsch, aber diese diese kryptischen, äh juristischen Formulierungen klingen für mich so ein bisschen nach,
solange man jetzt äh offiziell also nachweisen kann, dass man explizit dritten Zugang gegeben hat,
ist genau diese Störerhaftung gar nicht mehr gültig,
womit sie ja eigentlich komplett adopsur dumm ist, weil das war ja der Sinn der Störerhaftung, genau das sagen zu können. Du bist immer haftbar, selbst wenn du anderen Leuten Zugang gibst, also eigentlich ist ja diese Entscheidung.
Vielleicht lese ich da jetzt was falsches rein, aber für mich riecht das halt einfach nach die Störerhaftung widerspricht sich selbst und ist eigentlich ungültig.
Der Rechtsanwalt Christian Solmecke, wir zitiert mit, das bedeutet, dass der Anschlussinhaber in einem Fallsharing-Verfahren lediglich vortragen muss, dass dritte Zugriff auf den Anschluss hatten
oder der Anschluss nicht hinreichend gesichert war, um seiner sekundären Darlegungslast zu genügen.
Diese Konstellation ist auch auf Wohngemeinschaften übertragbar.
Sekundäre Darlegungslast.
Genau das. Naja, das weiß ich nicht genau, was das ist. Da hat er äh ausführlich zugeblockt. Wir werden das auch nochmal verlinken. Also es sieht im Moment danach aus, tatsächlich. Das ist der ähm also der Stand.
Ist auch auf Wohngemeinschaften übertragbar. Ich meine, im Prinzip ist das nichts anderes als die Akzeptanz der Realität, aber damit äh tut sich ja dann so die Öffentlichkeit eh immer ein bisschen schwer.
Ja, ich würde, ich würde befürchten,
dass dann sowas stattfindet wie im ähm im dass es endet, wie bei so etwas wie im Straßenverkehr, ne. Du kannst irgendwie dein Auto ähm anderen Personen äh zugänglich machen.
Wir mussten Fahrtenbuch führen.
Genau, also musst du nicht, aber wenn, wenn das dann zum wiederholten Male, dann kriegst du ja so eine Fahrtenbuchauflage. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das so in diese Richtung geht, ne.
Internetfahrtenbuch.
Ey, keine Ahnung, aber du weißt, was ich meine, ja. Also die Sache ist, wenn du ernsthaft, wenn du glaubhaft
versichern kannst, dass jemand mit deinem Fahrzeug gefahren ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt und du nicht genau weißt, wer das ist und diese Person sogar noch nicht einmal auf einem Foto erkennen kannst, beziehungsweise diese Person zwar auf einem Foto siehst, aber von deinem Zeugnis Verweigerungsrecht Gebrauch machst,
Klammer auf, bringt nix. Ich habe trotzdem die Punkte bekommen, als ich mit dem Auto von meiner Mutter mal in so eine kleine äh Situation kam. Da kam dann die äh äh Polizisten auch äh zu Hause vorbei.
Ja
Ja? Na also äh bringt nix. Aber ähm,
Ich denke, dass es in dass es so am Ende in diese Richtung geht, weil letztendlich wird, werden sich natürlich nicht alle Abmahnungen damit äh,
abbügeln lassen, dass man sagt, wieso muss ich das denn gewesen sein? Ich habe ja nur eine Sohn äh habe ich noch einen Sohn und eine Frau. Ne, und eine Tochter.
Ja oder ich habe meinen, äh wie heißt das so schön? Ich habe den Anschluss nicht hinreichend gesichert.
Ja und da gab's ja früher dann auch schon Urteile, die das eben anders gesehen haben,
und das quasi als zu einer Art äh Bürger äh Pflicht machen wollten. Aber wie gesagt, hier jetzt ähm äh Bundesgerichtshof in einer sehr ähm.
Schönen Einlassung. Also es sieht danach aus, dass diese Störerhaftung äh da eventuell.
Ne, dann doch mal äh.
Genau, also wir würden uns hier um juristische äh äh Kommentare auch freuen, wie ihr das so einschätzt. Wir denken jetzt mal, ausnahmsweise mal gute Nachrichten.
Also das auf jeden Fall, diese, was, was, äh, diese ganzen Urheberrechtssachen angeht, haben wir in den drei Urteilen denke ich auf jeden Fall erstmal positive Nachricht positive Nachrichten, dann werden wir mal sehen, äh, wie sich das dann.
In der in der Realität niederschlägt.
Realität, immer diese Realität.
Da müssen jetzt erstmal alle möglichen Abmahnanwälte erstmal wieder gucken wie sie da äh in Zukunft dran dann drum herum äh ruhten um dieses Problem.
Gut, schauen wir doch mal auf unsere Lieblingsthemen äh.
Ortszeitenspeicherung.
Ist ja mittlerweile nicht mehr ganz so verkrampftes ähm Thema. Jetzt wo auch international das so langsam kippt. Ich weiß nicht, hatten wir die Meldung, dass Dänemark äh was ist das letzte Mal dran?
Nee, haben wir nicht äh erwähnt.
Ja. Weil das ist ja sozusagen jetzt dem Ganzen noch vorhergegangen, also nach dem ja in Deutschland jetzt schon im Wesentlichen so die Ausgangslage sich so entwickelt mit na ja,
Jetzt gibt's irgendwie keine Richtlinie mehr, weil ist ja weg und so und äh wir machen das nicht, ob wir es immer noch eine Gruppe,
machen würde, hat man sich, glaube ich, in Dänemark äh in der Regierung mittlerweile dazu durchgerungen, keine.
Also, das war mir nicht bekannt. Ähm ich kenne also auch in Deutschland ist es natürlich so, dass der.
Mal den Link raus.
Das ist super, dann äh verlinken wir das. Ähm Thomas de Maizire sagt
äh ja nach wie vor, er hätte gerne eine kluge Verfassungsgemäße und mehrheitsfähige Neuregelung. Wir erinnern uns an seinen kleinen Konflikt mit dem äh Justizminister Heiko Maas, äh den er dann da äh irgendwann zu gegebener Stunde einmal
offensichtlich sehr zu sau gemacht haben muss nach hinter verschlossenen Türen.
Ähm aber wir wir sind noch gar nicht beim beim Thema. Anfang April wurde die äh Vorratsdatenspeicherungsrichtlinie gekippt.
Zwei Monate später hat die Justizministerin von Dänemark bekannt gegeben, dass auch bei
sich irgendwie fallen zu lassen, sehe ich gerade auf dem Bildschirm. So live wird das hier reingereicht und ähm die Cecilia Mainström,
bekannt als eine vehemente Verfechterin dieser ganzen Angelegenheit und so die treibende Kraft für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat jetzt auch.
Verlauten lassen, dass sie den Beschluss der luxemburger Richter sorgfältig analysiert hat und sich entschieden hat, keine neue Richtlinie vorzulegen.
Das würde sie allenfalls tun, wenn denn dann auch die Datenschutzrichtlinie verabschiedet ist.
Und mit der ist ja erst äh frühestens zweitausendfünfzehn zu rechnen.
Und unsere Bundesregierung, währenddessen, erinnern wir uns, haben wir auch schon gesagt, prüft und überlegt und äh versucht, ja? Ähnlich wie Generalbundesanwalt, Harald Ranger. Der prüft auch.
Wesentliche noch nur.
Genau, allerdings wird bei der Bundesregierung kann man eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass die nochmal irgendwann mit irgendeinem Mist um die Ecke kommen,
nämlich mit einer klugen, verfassungsgemäßen und mehrheitsfähigen Neuregelung. Ich war bei der Meldung so ein bisschen, ich hatte, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, diese Dänemark-Nummer nicht aufm Schirm,
Ähm.
Und mein eigentlicher, mein eigentlicher Eindruck war, dass die meinem Ström sich ja jetzt eigentlich auch zurücklehnen kann, weil so gut wie jeder europäische äh Mitgliedsstaat EU-Mitgliedsstaat das ja auch getan hat. Die haben die ja eh umgesetzt,
bis auf wenige Länder. Das heißt, sie hat ja quasi äh ihre Tat zu achtzig Prozent vollbracht,
Ja, die äh die die Europäische Union äh mit diesem Unsinn äh zu segnen. Das heißt, sie braucht sich jetzt eigentlich auch nicht mehr großartig die Blöße zu geben, noch eine neue ähm,
derartige Richtlinie zu verfassen, weil der Schaden ist ja jetzt da,
und andere äh andere Länder, wie wir wissen, verhandeln gerade über Verlängerung. Ihr habt das ausführlich ähm okay, jetzt mit mit Erik besprochen. Die Schweiz ist da kein gutes Beispiel.
Ja und äh,
um diesen Artikel nochmal etwas näher zu führen. Hier ist ja auch davon die Rede, dass in der Slowakei auch äh das Gesetz zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh suspendiert wurde. Österreich steht jetzt äh die Tage, wo
Woche an und äh da das ja nun alles auch von Österreich ausgegangen ist, nehme ich mal an, wird das eine ganze Menge Welle,
machen, da können wir dann vielleicht auch Thomas nochmal äh zu befragen. Ja, also,
Ich will hier nicht zu viel Optimismus verbreiten, aber nachdem es jetzt einfach jahrelang immer alles immer nur bedrohlicher geworden ist, ist jetzt zumindest mal so ein bisschen Ausatmen äh angesagt und ähm,
die Augen, ja, dass auf einmal zumindest ausgewählte äh äh Regierungen der Meinung sind, ach.
Jetzt gibt's keine Richtlinie,
Übrigens, wir haben uns das jetzt mal wirklich angeschaut und festgestellt, es hat auch keinen Nutzen, sondern es kostet einfach nur eine Menge Geld, nichts anderes haben wir bisher alle Studien darüber, äh, gesagt, ja? Äh von Zeit zu Zeit
scheint es dann doch so zu sein, dass man in der Exekutive das ein oder anderen Staates sich auch mal nach der Realität richtet. Ist ja auch was Schönes. Ob das jetzt ähm,
Hobbycharakter hat, kann ich nicht sagen. Grundsätzlich ähm sind die Skandinavia ja ohnehin so,
Dänemark kann ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so gut einschätzen. Schweden ist da nochmal so ein anderes Thema, ja also,
so die äh das Selbstverständnis der Verdatung der Gesellschaft ist da einfach ein anderes, ja? So mit offenen Einnahme äh Verzeichnissen et cetera. Das äh ist ja einfach,
etwas ist dort Normalität, was zum Beispiel bei uns einfach Hassobjekt Nummer eins wäre, ne. Nun denn.
Ja, also wir wir können da gespannt schauen, was sich noch anmerken möchte ist, ähm dass sie,
ähm dass die äh dänische Justizministerin Karen das auch da mit also auf einer Evidenzbasierten Analyse begründet und sagt, es scheint,
nicht das Ziel zu dem Ziel zu dienen, irgendwie bei der Strafverfolgung sinnvoll zu sein?
Das heißt, sie macht da nicht den den bürgerrechtler und sagt äh äh so einen Mist haben wir nicht nötig, sondern sie ähm macht das evidenzbasiert,
und das war übrigens auch etwas, was ich äh in meinem Bundestagsausschuss digitale Agenda ähm Stellungnahme sehr ausführlich dargestellt habe, dass äh man sich bei solchen
Grundrechtsbeschränkenden einschränkenden äh Gesetzgebungen. Doch bitte,
auf äh auf Empirie auch verlassen sollen müsste und vor allem äh,
zum Beispiel solche Gesetze für einen, wenn überhaupt, nur auf eine bestimmte Zeit zu beschließen und zu sagen, nach so und so vielen Jahren kommt das Gesetz ob seiner äh Effektivität auf den Prüfstand,
und wenn es nichts bringt oder nur wenig bringt,
oder der Nutzen eben den Kosten äh zu den Kosten in keinerlei sinnvollen Verhältnis steht, dann ist es eben vorbei, dann wird's nicht verlängert. Also Gesetze mit äh Ablaufdatum. Auch schön.
Genau, also vor allem mit einem definierten Ende und man muss explizit beschließen, dass man's weiterführt. Es gibt ja auch so ein bisschen das Gegenteil mit äh wir wir planen in zehn Jahren noch mal zu prüfen, ob wir es noch brauchen so, ja und wenn nichts getan wird, bleibt's.
Genau, ja. Naja, also äh spannend.
Ja
Auch spannend sind Veröffentlichungen von äh Vodafone. Man gewinnt auch hier so ein wenig den Eindruck, dass äh trotz aller allgemeinen Blindheit gegenüber der
aufgedeckten im letzten Jahr aufgedeckten Überwachungsskandale schon hier und da, zumindest im Businessbereich, ähm das eine Wirkung erzielt,
Nur so jetzt im,
Internet-Cloud-Bereich, wo die Firmen ja so ein bisschen Panik haben, ihre Dienste überhaupt noch an äh den Mann und die Frau zu bringen.
Sondern auch die Mobilfunker sehen sich wohl in zunehmenden Maße äh unter Druck. Und so hat äh Vodafone, ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie das angekündigt hatten, dass sie das tun würden.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie's angekündigt haben.
Nichts von gehört, zumindest.
Das Entscheidende ist, Vodafone Group. Nicht äh Vodafone Deutschland oder so, sondern direkt.
Das Vodafone aller Vodafones.
Die Mutter aller Vodafone.
Vodafone und äh haben einen Bericht herausgebracht über Love for Interception. Ähm,
wo sie Einblicke geben, jetzt bin ich grade am Schwimmen, weil ich das nicht gelesen habe, sondern nur berichte dadrüber, nennen sie Länder oder sagen sie nur allgemein, es gibt Länder, das ist.
Also ein für jedes einzelne ihrer Länder. Das heißt, sie sie schreiben äh für jedes Land, in dem sie vertreten sind. Ähm,
relativ ausführlich, wie es dort aussieht in Sachen Loveul Intersept. Und ähm.
Sie schreiben dann auch relativ ausführlich darüber, in welchen Ländern sie wozu keine Aussage treffen konnten.
Und da ist es zum Beispiel ganz äh ganz interessant zu sehen,
Ich komme ja auch mit den Fenstern auch nicht zurecht. Ähm dass sie sagen, ähm in einigen Ländern,
haben die Behörden direkten Zugang zu den Netzen. Also es geht dabei jetzt hauptsächlich um das ähm Abhören von mobiler Telefonie mit Hilfe,
der,
Infrastruktur des Anbieters, ja? Du könntest ja auch einen Imse-Katcher benutzen oder ähm ähm andere Möglichkeiten, vielleicht ein ein Virus auf dem Handy, aber du kannst natürlich auch immer sehr schön zu dem Anbieter selber gehen,
und ähm das,
sogenannte äh betrifft also die Abhörmöglichkeiten, Abheuerkapazitäten, technischen äh Möglichkeiten, die diese Anbieter,
bereithalten für solche Fälle. Von denen sie natürlich sehr viele äh Anfragen bekommen.
Und
darüber hat ja ursprünglich vor ein paar Wochen dann die Deutsche Telekom in Deutschland zum ersten Mal so eine Art Transparenzbericht verfasst, wo wir dann gesehen haben, wie viele zehntausend äh verschiedene Anfragen, die jeweils bekommen haben
Und Vodafone hat jetzt das Gleiche getan für im Prinzip alle Länder, äh in denen sie vertreten sind. Ähm,
Deutschland, sagen sie, äh gehört nicht zu den Ländern, wo die Behörden direkten Zugang zu den Netzen hätten?
Mhm. Ähm in anderen Ländern ist das der Fall. Ähm jedes Land aber.
Direkt heißt, dass quasi der Staat selber per technischer Fernwirkung, Daten und Zugriff sofort erlangen kann, versus es gibt einen bürokratischen Prozess, wo man einen solchen Zugriff,
ähm ja, entweder durchführen lassen kann oder äh nach Absprache herstellt, was auch immer.
Genau. Und da gibt's äh da gibt's in der Tat unterschiedliche unterschiedliche Regelungen, ne, also was ähm oder unterschiedliche Lösungen, die dann die Provider auch bereitstellen. Ähm,
Schön ist halt, so was, wenn man einfach nur wirklich einen port dupliziert und das alles wegpeilt äh zu den zu den Behörden, die schon wissen, was sie tun,
sieht man auch in in einigen europäischen Ländern.
Schön sind auch, kenne ich einen Fall, äh der gehört nicht zur Vodafone-Gruppe, wo ähm sich der Anbieter zumindest die das Befolgen dieser Anfragen dann auch bezahlen lässt,
Das heißt, sie haben äh haben im Prinzip eine Preisliste, die sie die der Polizei dann auch äh äh entsprechend bekannt ist.
Weil sie sagen, na ja, dieses ganze Op, Abhör-Equipment, was wir hier aufstellen, das kostet ja auch ein Schweinegeld, das muss hier irgendwie refinanzieren.
Gehst also ganz ganz unterschiedliche Regelungen und äh wo davon hat das jetzt mal sehr ausführlich äh äh dargestellt. Und da kann man eigentlich davon ausgehen, da wurde von irgendwie in über zwanzig Ländern vertreten ist, dass das, was Vodafone dafür ein einzelnes Land schildert
in der Regel dann wahrscheinlich für alle anderen Provider in diesen in diesem Land ebenfalls so ähm,
der Fall ist.
Was mich ja mal interessieren würde, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das schon stattgefunden hat, sieht jetzt gerade auf den ersten Blick,
Ah doch hier, genau, hier, genau, das ist so eine genauso eine Tabelle, wollte ich gerade sehen. Hat also schon jemand gemacht, die Tabelle war aber jetzt so nicht Teil dieses Berichts, oder?
Ähm dann habe ich die wahrscheinlich, habe ich nicht alle vollständigen Links, ja, also müssen wir mal gucken.
Ja, aber das ist natürlich mal jetzt sehr interessant. Das ist äh halt ein Überblick,
überhaupt von welchen Ländern, in welcher Größenordnung äh geholt wird. Also das geht hier von Vodafone Metadata, Vodafone Content,
nicht ganz genau, was äh Vodafone-Content jetzt ist, National Meterdater heißt das, dass dann sozusagen auch hier so äh die eigentlichen Userkonten das damit gemeint?
Da müssten wir dann den diesen Guardian Artikel, den wir gerade vor uns haben, dann auch schon durchaus gelesen haben.
Ja. Ja, man sollte vorher wissen, was man.
Ja, aber sehr interessant sind natürlich auch so Linda wie Katar, äh Rumänien, Südafrika, Türkei,
Einschränkungen auch äh Malta, Ungarn, Indien,
Ägypten und Albanien, das sind nämlich jetzt die, wo hier dicker, schwarzer Balken ist, wo einfach steht
Es ist verboten, irgendetwas darüber zu sagen, ne, also so ähnlich wie das auch in den USA ist und dann finde ich das auch schon mal ganz spannend, dass sie also auch schon mal ähm zwei Mitglieder der Europäischen Union, die drei sogar dabei sind, ne, also.
Ist sogar noch spannender.
Von Ungarn ist man das jetzt schon mittlerweile gewohnt. Rumänien noch nicht ganz so. Malta hatte ich noch keine Vorstellung.
Es gibt einmal die Länder, in denen sie überhaupt nichts darüber sagen dürfen und es gibt, ist eigentlich ein sehr schöner äh Nebensatz zu diesem Bericht ist, es gibt,
also in über einige Anfragen darf nicht berichtet werden und wird auch in diesen äh Bericht nicht berichtet. Ja, also es äh,
interessant.
Aber es gibt auch Länder, in denen sozusagen nichts stattfindet.
Na ja, ähm was ist das, Motz.
Weiß ich nicht, aber äh es gibt hier Kenia, Ghana, wo irgendwie.
Nichts drin steht.
Ja wo nichts steht. Also aber ich meine, wenn sie jetzt darüber berichten.
Was ist das? Mosambik.
Kann sein. Okay, also spannend, schön sind, man sieht immer wieder schöne, große Zahlen. Ähm und was
Was dann natürlich auch sehr ähm ne, dreiundzwanzigtausend Mal äh Content anfragen und was der,
Teil war, der jetzt zu meiner allgemeinen Überraschung für äh allgemeine Überraschungen sorgte,
war, dass sie solche Schnittstellen vorhalten.
Das war also so die Meldung wie Vodafone äh erklärt, dass sie sowas vorhalten müssen, natürlich. Ist auch eingebaut in die meisten Geräte. Ja, das ist immer bei,
hatte ich ja schon mal angesprochen, als äh Sigmar Gabriel, dann sagte, ja hier äh Abhör äh Equipment darf nicht mehr exportiert werden,
Diese Funktionalität ist natürlich ähm in der Regel auch eingebaut
Ja, das heißt, da da kriegst du die jetzt nicht ein äh Mobilfunknetzkern, den man nicht abhören könnte.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wird's äh diese diese Versuch, das alles zu verbieten darin am Gipfeln, dass halt irgendwie die Software zwar ausgeliefert wird, wie sonst auch, aber diese Konfigurationsdatei schaltet das Feature aus.
Ja, mal schauen, also aber ich denke, wir brauchen da jetzt auch nicht so weiter drüber zu reden, so ist ganz klar äh Provider kooperieren. Es geht in jedem äh Land Gesetze, die sie dazu zwingen,
ähm eigentlich alles nichts Neues. Das Schöne ist, dass da jetzt mal sehr ausführlich Zahlen genannt wurden.
Naja, also wir Linken hier auf jeden Fall auch noch auf den Guardian Artikel, ja.
Ja, ist schon längst geschehen.
Und äh vielleicht kann ja jemand auch nochmal mit ein bisschen mehr Verständnis dadrüber schauen und ein paar Schlussfolgerungen daraus ziehen. Äh was ich mal sehr interessant fände und was auch die Tabelle des Guardians so nicht hergibt, ist,
inwiefern sich eben jetzt die hier aufgeführten Zugriffsarten und Mengen äh gegebenenfalls noch etwas zisilierter
visualisieren lässt, also gar nicht mal nur so so das wie viel, sondern auch welche Art von Zugriff überhaupt
äh gewährt wird und auch gerade diese Unterscheidung mit äh direkter Zugriff nicht direkter Zugriff. Das wäre doch mal sehr interessant, um sich einfach ein besseres Bild äh zu machen und das Ganze dann vielleicht auch auf so eine kleine Heatmap äh auf die einzelnen Länder
umzusetzen.
Haben einige versucht ähm ja also wie gesagt, dieses ich bin diesem Thema gegenüber so ein bisschen ähm.
Indifferent das jetzt noch irgendwie weiter zu,
irgendwie darstellungsmäßig zu vertiefen. Tatsache ist, äh dass diese Schnittstellen da sind und dass es jetzt ein Fakt, der mir persönlich ähm,
seit sehr langer Zeit so bekannt ist.
Ja gut, aber etwas.
Ich auch ausführlich schon berichtet habe.
Genau, aber das ist ja das das generelle Dilemma in diesen Debatten. Da ist einigen Experten einiges mögliches erkannt, ja? Äh bekannt.
Nur ein offizielles PDF von Vodafone, wo drinsteht äh hier, wir tun das. Ja, das kann man einfach Leuten auch auf den Tisch knallen und sagen, hier Realität.
Schön ist vor allem, dass man jetzt hoffentlich davon ausgehen kann, dass Vodafone es äh Google gleich tun wird, die diesen Transparency Report ja nicht nur veröffentlichen, sondern jährlich veröffentlichen. Und mit Trends versehen.
Und das denke ich, da werden dann äh so Dinge auch nochmal äh interessant. Sie nämlich in so einer
im Lenkschnitt auch zu sehen. Wie hat sich das wie hat sich denn die Anzahl der Anfragen in den Ländern entwickelt? Sie ist natürlich gestiegen, wie stark ist sie gestiegen? Ist sie stärker in der Türkei gestiegen als im im Vereinigten Königreich? Und sowas, ne? Wer ähm,
Wie ist der ähm wie ist der Anstieg der Neuüberwachung oder wie wir das mal genannt? Wie ist die, wurde die die Neuüberwachung gedeckelt und sowas, ne?
Ja. Gut. Ähm was mal was mal einen anderen Programmpunkt stark macht.
Genau, Bundeswehr? Bundeswehr. Schön, Bundeswehr. Verteidigungsministerium hat am äh fünften äh Februar März eine,
Kleine Anfrage der Abgeordneten André Hunkow, Wolfgang Gerke und Annette Groth und einigen anderen Mitgliedern der Linkspartei äh beantwortet,
Und in dieser kleinen Anfrage wurde unter anderem die Frage gestellt, ob denn irgendwie Bestrebungen bestünden ähm,
Twitter und Facebook auszuwerten, irgendwie soziale Medien zu untersuchen, auch über diese Antwort hatten wir über diese kleine Anfrage hatten wir äh hier berichtet
Und da wurde also gesagt, wo dann von der Bundesregierung, die ja diese kleine Anfrage beantwortet hat, gesagt, nö, da haben wir also keine ähm haben wir keine Bestrebungen im Moment, da äh soziale Netze irgendwie auszuwerten.
Und jetzt äh wurde diese Aussage zwei Monate später berichtigt, denn es gab huch ein Büroversehen. Es gab ein Büro versehen, huch.
Es gab ein Büro versehen. Büroversehen.
Genau, denn das Verteidigungsministerium unterstützt mit eins Komma drei fünf Millionen Euro. Ein Fraunhofer-Forschungsprojekt, das sich mit der Wissenserschließung aus offenen Quellen,
befasst.
W wissen nee, nee, also wer wissenserschließung offenen Quellen.
Ja, das ist eine dieser schönen Abkürzungen.
Das ist so in Deutschland werden immer so blöde Abkürzungen gesucht und danach versucht man noch irgendwas zu deuteln, wie man das jetzt,
noch nicht mal passiert. Hier würde einfach nur eine Abkürzung für irgend so eine komische Formulierung genommen.
Da sollte man sich mal bei der NSA wirklich mal ein Beispiel nehmen, ja? Ich meine, die haben da wirklich Flammenschwerter und äh.
Andere wirklich gewichtige äh Götter am Start so. Das macht einfach was her. Wo bleibt denn die PR?
Ja, also was war denn jetzt genau das Büro versehen, dass man darauf geantwortet hat.
Behauptet hat, soziale Medien würden nicht betrachtet,
Gleichzeitig aber das Verteidigungsministerium ein Forschungsprojekt finanziert unterhält, in dem die Erforschung sozialer Medien zu Zwecken der Verteidigung ähm stattfindet.
Also was ist denn nun? Findet's jetzt statt oder nicht?
Sie investieren zumindest also ich kann's ja nochmal wiederholen. Es wurde gefragt, macht ihr das oder beabsichtigt ihr das zu tun? Es wurde geantwortet mit nein. Und zwei Monate und das war ein Büro versehen. Das war Büro versehen. Huch,
Büro versehen.
Da sagten sie, sie machen's eigentlich nicht, aber es gibt zumindest dieses Projekt.
So und jetzt haben sie diese kleine Anfrage quasi äh zwei Monate später äh dann irgendwie noch so gesagt, ah übrigens uns ist da ein Büroversehen aufgefallen.
Unsere Antwort auf die äh kleine Anfrage war aufgrund eines Büroversehens nicht. Wahrheitsgemäß.
Und das äh interessant, weil die Anfragen der Linksfraktion, das sind wirklich ähm ich zitiere die ja relativ häufig und wir haben dafür schon äh dadurch sehr viele Dinge ähm,
über diesen Politikbetrieb äh und über Sachen, die verheimlicht äh wurden.
Ähm oder die wir auf anderem Wege nicht ans Licht bekommen hätten, erfahren.
Wir hatten auch schon mal darüber gesprochen, dass ja äh,
gezielt gestreut wurde, die Linksfraktion äh mache,
betreibe damit irgendwie eine Unterstützung von terroristischen oder militanten Umtrieben in Deutschland, in dem sie diese Anfragen stellt, deren Antworten dann öffentlich frei verfügbar sind.
Und wenn da jetzt, wenn sie jetzt da irgendwie auch noch unwahre Antworten bekommen, dann ist das schon eine sehr starke ähm,
sehr starkes Stück und seine eine sehr äh erstaunliche Behinderung der Arbeit,
der Opposition. Denn diese kleinen Anfragen sind mit,
einzige warum so eine Oppositionsarbeit auch nach wie vor sinnvoll ist, warum es sich überhaupt, warum es überhaupt sinnvoll ist, sich in der Opposition zu unterhalten in einem Parlament, wo äh ja ohnehin in dieser Debatte im Parlament nicht stattfindet. Das heißt, wenn die sowieso nicht da sind,
in der Willensbildung im Prinzip die ganze Zeit nicht vertreten sind,
Dann könnte man sicher auch sagen, komm, wir sparen uns die Kohle. Aber kleine Anfragen sind unter anderem eben ein sehr wirkungsvolles Mittel und ähm sind äh sind immer zu begrüßen.
Und es ist natürlich sehr übel, wenn wenn da äh irgendwie mit Verarsche äh reagiert wird.
Ja, wir begrüßen es auf jeden Fall.
Klar, die Antwort natürlich nicht.
Denn, also finde ich auch interessant, Fraunhofer, ne, alle finden immer Fraunhofer toll. Eins Komma drei fünf Millionen, um irgendwie soziale Netzwerke auszuforschen. Äh wird äh wird finanziell nicht reichen,
Ist aber natürlich trotzdem schade um das Geld. Ja, weil das jetzt weg. Da ist er jetzt bei denen.
Tja, ja, so ist das. Kurz, kommen wir, wissen.
Zum letzten Thema, ja.
Wir kommen zum letzten Thema und das finde ich das ist irgendwie das ist ein.
Delikatesse der Open Source, nee, Open Source, ist ja gar nicht. Ist es?
Ähm ja, diese Katisse der Softwareentwicklung, also,
Ich hab's noch nicht so ganz verstanden, aber es gibt ein Produkt, das heißt True Cript,
was ich sagen wir mal auch der Kryptogemeinde recht großer Beliebtheit erfreut hat kann man so sagen oder?
Weil ich das wirklich noch nie verwendet habe. Äh zum Verschlüsseln von Festplatten. Es gibt schon ein bisschen mehr,
und das kann man halt benutzen, um so eine Festplatte zu verschlüsseln. Was ja erstmal eine tolle Sache ist, weil.
Könnt ihr mal versuchen, drauf zu schauen und offensichtlich haben das auch viele Leute verwendet. Und äh vor ein paar Wochen, wie lange ist das jetzt her? Eine Woche.
Einer Woche ungefähr.
Einer Woche, genau, gab's dann auf einmal, ob's pure Meldungen,
von dieser Entwicklergemeinde so nach dem Motto ja äh,
Übrigens, Warnung, Warnung, Druckkript ist nicht sicher
weil es irgendwie äh nicht behobene Sicherheitsfehler enthält und äh benutzt auch besser äh das entsprechende Produkt von äh Windows, wie heißt das noch gleich? Ich bin
Bitlocker,
Und ja und das war's so. Außerdem sind die alten Versionen vom Netz genommen worden. Es gab nur eine aktuelle Version, die nur noch äh Daten wiederherstellen kann,
und keine Erklärung, nix irgendwie alles total im Unklaren.
Kleiner, kurzer äh Exkurs noch. Aufgrund der nicht unter einer der anerkannten,
Open Source die Zinsen veröffentlicht ist, geht es,
äh Anhängern der Reihen leere nicht als Open Source Software, weil ich gerade so leichtfertig sagte, doch das ist Open Source,
ja. Aber ähm das nur am Rande. Genau, dieses da haben das haben sehr viele Menschen äh genutzt
Container. Hatte unter anderem auch diese schöne, also es hatte eine Funktion, um die gesamte Festplatte zu verschlüsseln, also unter anderem für äh für Windows-Rechner. Es hatte eine,
ähm,
ein äh schönes äh die schöne Möglichkeit eines versteckten Volumes. Das heißt, man konnte einen erstellen und in diesem einen weiteren äh Versteck
was so auf diese Julian Assange äh Nummer zurückging mit dem mit dem Gummiknüppel, ne, das heißt ähm.
Loggen sie sich mal ein am Flughafen und so und dann.
Die wissen ja, die wissen ja immerhin, dass du einen hast, ja, also können sie dich auch mit der,
Zange zwingen, den das Passwort dazu herauszurücken, aber wenn nicht nachweisbar ist, dass sich darin noch ein weiterer versteckter befindet, dann kannst du wenigstens diesen plausibel ähm,
verneinen die Existenz dieses Zweiten. Das heißt, du machst irgendwie so ein bisschen Alibi Porn in einen äh Container und in den Rest äh in in den Freibleibenden Speicherplatz, dieses Containers, der natürlich Zufall ist,
damit sein dadrin versteckst du eine zweite Verschlüsselung in der du dann Dokumente hast. Zum Beispiel,
All solche schönen Features und alle haben irgendwie auf dieses auf dieses Tool geschwört und erst vor kurzem ähm gab es auch ein ein Audit. Da wurde ähm,
wenn ich mich recht entsinne, dafür gesammelt, weil man nämlich sagte, Moment mal, wenn jetzt hier NSA und so, dann sollten wir doch mal
ein Audit äh dieser Software durchführen, auf die wir uns so sehr verlassen. Nicht, dass sich dadrin nachher noch ein kleiner versteckt oder so. Wobei das Lied,
Da gab's also einen Audit und da der Audit-Bericht war ähm.
So wie man ihn erwartet, da wurden ein paar äh sage ich mal Best Practice Verletzungen drin gefunden, aber irgendwie kein äh kein offenes Scheunentor, was jetzt alle zu Panik veranlasst hätte. Und es stand auch schon der zweite Teil dieses Audits, äh bevor,
ja? Und ähm war oder ist äh
immer sowas gewesen, wo man wo man sagt, ja so, das haben wir noch, ne? Wir haben noch.
Und ähm jetzt das.
Ja, vor allem mit dieser merkwürdigen Mail. Also, es war einfach sehr, sehr unklar. Mittlerweile gibt's ein paar nach äh,
gereichte Meldungen, die auch genauso unklar sind, unter anderem habe ein Entwickler gegenüber diesem auditierenden Menschen äh erklärt. Es gebe jetzt kein Interesse mehr, äh diese Software weiterzuentwickeln,
Bei den äh Autoren so und äh sie werden jetzt auch nicht besonders begeistert bei dem Gedanken, dass eine Community diese Arbeit jetzt ähm übernehmen könnte, sollte,
Was ja wohl dann eben auch noch eine wo wahrscheinlich gegebenenfalls noch eine Lizenzänderung erforderlich ist,
Ähm mir ist nicht so ganz klar, wo die Einschränkungen dieser Lizenz ist, dass sie nicht äh einer der allgemein akzeptierten Open-Sours-Lizenzen entspricht.
Es ist mir jetzt im im Detail auch nicht bekannt.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall äh gibt's da auf jeden Fall Fragen und ja, die die Entwickler ziehen sich zurück und meinen, so Nix hält ewig und ja, was wollt ihr denn überhaupt?
Ja, es äh also was.
Sehr merkwürdig.
Sie sie auf dieser nun verbleibenden Seite steht zweimal in Rot. Ist insecure.
Ja
So, das ist also, wenn man jetzt mal
wir wir müssen natürlich jetzt ein bisschen spekulieren, ne? Aber wenn sie das zweimal rot da drauf schreiben als Entwickler, die jahrelang an diesem Projekt äh gearbeitet haben, was eine sehr große Verbreitung gefunden hat
ähm dann denke ich, dass sie äh einen entscheidenden Grund dazu haben, diese Äußerung dort so einzubringen.
Freies Warum haben sie keinen entscheidenden Grund, diese Äußerungen auch mal zu konkretisieren?
So und das wird doch im Zweifel damit zu tun haben.
Dass sie es nicht sagen können.
Dass sie es nicht sagen dürfen.
Sie dürfen nicht sagen, dass.
Sein, dass sich äh also ne, dass sie einer,
Einem solchen Gag-Order unterliegen oder irgendwie Post bekommen haben oder Besuch von irgendeiner Regierungsstelle, die sagt, übrigens äh wir möchten bitte.
Du eine Hintertür einbaust oder wir möchten bitte, dass du eine Hintertür ausnutzt oder sonstiges,
Und das ist ja so das äh der Fachbegriff, der sich dafür äh ja so ein bisschen her äh herausstilisiert hat, ist der eines,
eines Kanarienvogels. Äh in Anlehnung an die äh Kanarienvögel, die Minenarbeiter mitgenommen haben in äh früher,
Weil diese Vögel irgendwie reagiert haben, wenn zu viel Grubengas da war. Das heißt, es herrscht Explosionsgefahr. Ähm,
Das heißt, es war ein warnendes Ding. Solange der irgendwie der Kanarienvogel da irgendwie sich normal verhalten hat, war auch alles in Ordnung. Ähm,
Und worüber sich Menschen Gedanken machen, ist,
wie kann ich denn dafür sorgen, dass ein, wenn ich einmal auf einmal von den National Security Letter bekomme und auf einmal das FBI vor der Tür steht und sagt, hier alles rausrücken, du darfst aber nichts erzählen.
Ähm wie kann ich dafür sorgen, dass diese Information trotzdem,
anderen Menschen, meinen Nutzern mitgeteilt wird. Was einige machen, ist zum Beispiel, dass sie äh jetzt irgendwie wöchentlich oder im zweiwöchentlichen Abstand ähm eine PGP signierte Nachricht schreiben und sagen, in den letzten beiden Wochen haben.
Keine Anfragen.
Gab es keine Anfragen. Ja und jetzt könnten jetzt,
Die graue Theorie will es, dass sie jetzt sich einbilden, dass wenn sie einen National Security Letter bekommen.
Dass sie das dann einfach sein lassen dürfen.
Sein lassen, ja? Und nicht jemand mit einem Gummiknüppel da steht und sagt, Freundchen, gib mal dem, mit dem du das alles unterzeichnet hast, so wir sind ja nicht blöd. So,
Aber so und da werden also unterschiedliche Verfahren äh gewählt äh um um einen solchen Cannay ähm.
So ein Kanarienvogel zu implementieren. Und hatte jetzt meines Wissens einen solchen nicht. Und jetzt könnte es natürlich sein,
wenn man sie zu völlig irre Verschwörungstheorie äh entfalten möchte, dass sich tatsächlich in eine äh eine Sicherheitslücke befindet,
Und die Entwickler ähm vielleicht auch gar nicht wissen, welche das ist.
Oder eine sehr großen, ein sehr klaren Anlass haben, diese Sicherheitslücke nicht zu fixen.
Und deswegen sagen, okay, dann machen wir das ganze Ding zu. Ähnlich wie dieser. Äh äh Gründer, der gesagt hat, okay, wenn das so ist.
Dann kann ich hier überhaupt.
Dann mache ich hier, dann lösche ich all eure E-Mails, Kunden, liebe Kunden, macht den Dienst sofort zu und handle somit in eurem Interesse.
Ähm.
Andererseits würde man, und das ist natürlich der, der andere entscheidende Punkt, wenn ich als Trucryp Entwickler, sage ich mal, mit Daumenschrauben und allem, äh,
gefangen bin und nicht ähm verraten darf, dass sich in wie die Sicherheitslücke gestaltet ist, die sich in meinem Produkt befindet,
Aber wenn ich trotzdem Kenntnis über diese Sicherheitslücke hätte
dann würden mir ja irgendwelche Wege einfallen, dass irgendeine unbekannter Security-Researcher plötzlich auf ähm mal kurz schreibt, ach guck mal, was ich hier äh herausgefunden habe.
Und ist natürlich schon erstaunlich, dass sie diesen Weg,
nicht gehen und das lässt natürlich so ein bisschen das öffnet jetzt irgendwie für alle Arten von Spekulationen, äh Tür und Tor.
Die Spekulationen, die haben auch gerade erst so richtig äh angefangen,
Es ist einfach äh noch unvollendet diese ganze Debatte. Wir werden das vielleicht begleiten, wenn sich da irgendwas Interessantes ergibt. Ja, für Leute, die Druckkript einsetzen ist auch sehr schwer zu sagen, was man da jetzt überhaupt empfehlen soll,
Ja, ich meine, gibt's denn überhaupt noch eine andere äh Plattenverschlüsselung, die Open Source ist, die in irgendeiner Form Vertrauen hat.
Mir ist jetzt nicht unbedingt eine bekannt.
Ähm wie gesagt, die Betriebssysteme haben inzwischen selbst eine eine mitgelieferte, aber das sind äh die großen Betriebssysteme, Hersteller sind äh.
Auf der Prison Liste Microsoft und Apple. Ähm ich weiß, dass auch eine voll das anrät und die basiert nicht auf Turpt,
sondern äh man, wie heißt er, ich glaube oder sowas. Ich ähm,
aktiviere das immer nur kurz und weiß nicht genau, äh.
Du schaltest da einfach irgendwas ein und weißt nicht so ganz genau, was das ist, aber stand sicher drauf, passt schon.
Ja, mal gucken, was mit ähm,
oder Krypto Loop. Okay, es gibt verschiedene Fahnen, Verfahren für Linox, die also machen. Wobei ich aber äh also
Hatte natürlich eine starke Verbreitung, weil sie eben für Windows gemacht haben. Das ist ja so ein kleines Problem, dass wir dann äh den Bootloder irgendwie nochmal selber schreiben musst, damit der das Ding irgendwie entschlüsselt und das System in einen butbaren Zustand ähm versetzt,
ähm aber ich,
mein Eindruck war eigentlich das hauptsächlich wegen dieser Containerfalls genutzt wurde. Also für es war immer ganz angenehm. Du konntest irgendwie und äh App
äh auf einen USB-Stick haben, der neben dem Container und du hattest irgendwie einen schönen äh verschlüsselten USB-Stick,
den du einer anderen Person geben konntest, Nico von dem USB-Stick starten, um das äh um die Inhalte zu entschlüsseln, ne. Ähm,
Das waren schon immer ganz, ganz feine Sachen. Es kursiert natürlich auch noch die Überlegung, ob die vielleicht einfach nur gehackt wurden und jemand, den einen sehr, sehr üblen Streich spielt.
Ja, es ist äh unklar.
Aber man ist halt sehr, man, man, so wie's jetzt aussieht, ähm werden natürlich äh sehr, sehr viele Spekulationen,
äh können jetzt getätigt werden, die ähm.
Allen möglichen Nährboden haben in dem, was was man dort vorfindet.
Na, wir hatten ja auch schon lange keine neuen Verschwörungstheorien mehr.
Das wäre, das ist aber jetzt echt mal ja, also ich weiß ja gar nicht genau, was ich davon äh was ich davon denke, also so irgendwie dieses knallrote und so.
Ja und jetzt.
Nächste Woche stellen wir den Distanzrekord auf. Kündige ich jetzt hier mal vollmundig an.
Hm, denn wie weit sind wir auseinander ähm.
Casting, Podcasting, Distanzrekord.
Na, das sind ja Versprechungen, die wir hier machen. Ob's leere Versprechungen sein werden, das werdet ihr dann äh irgendwann nächste Woche feststellen.
Tschüss, was? Ciao, ciao. Bis bald.